[Musica]
[Applauso]
come son contento di essere qui stasera
qual è
la vostra passione
e quando avete giocato
l'ultima volta
vi do qualche secondo per pensarci
può essere un gioco come un bimbo
spensierato oppure come un maestro di
scacchi
professionista
professionale
mirato analitico
e io credo che
il disegno possa essere un gioco la
pittura per me lo è stato fino a quando
ero ragazzino
è che il gioco come come l'arte sia una
celebrazione della vita
possa essere o comunque nasca da questo
oggi abbiamo visto l'opera di boys e
nelle sue lavagne nella prima delle sue
lavagne la definizione di arte è
d'accordo con me
anche un altro mio maestro d'accordo
alejandro jodorowsky dice che l'arte è
sempre creativa non è mai distruttiva
il gesto artistico è sempre creativo
volevo farvi vedere delle delle opere
che abbiamo fatto in maniera molto
spontanea assieme ai miei miei compagni
di strada i miei amici tanti anni fa a
milano queste sono delle fotografie
circa del 2003 2004 quindi sono quasi
quasi 20 anni e anche
dovete fare uno sforzo perché di fatto
queste che ci sembrano a noi
cose scontate oggi io passeggiavo per
perugia ed effettivamente si vedono
adesivi tech ci sono degli spot si
dicono così in gergo dove i graffitari e
gli artisti
intervengono
e ormai in tutte le città si trovano
anche anche qua però vent'anni fa questo
spettacolo questo questi questi adesivi
questi disegni erano all'avanguardia
prima c'erano solo i graffiti ed in
effetti ho iniziato con il graffito per
lo meno diciamo che i graffiti sono
stati parte della mia della mia del mio
gioco gioco anche un po rischioso perché
come sapete sono scappata dai gendarmi
può essere un po complicato
dopo i graffiti ci sono state c'è stata
quella che è stata chiamata street art
1.0 ovvero la peg che nessuno riesce a
decodificare che sono scarabocchi per
tutti tranne che per i raffinati per
affittare la tec è
un qualcosa che ogni graffitaro mette a
scrivere il proprio nome
quindi sostituendola tech con
un'immagine circa 20 anni fa abbiamo
creato una piccola rivoluzione
e questa piccola rivoluzione ha
influenzato e sta influenzando tutt'oggi
quello che è il
l'immaginario
il costume la musica è anche l'arte
fate un piccolo sforzo perché come vi
dicevo queste questo genere di arte
queste immagini che vi faccio vedere di
vent'anni fa
sono ormai ma le diamo per scontate come
diamo per scontato ad esempio lo
smartphone vivere con uno smartphone
avere i social però vent'anni fa nel
2003 2004 gli smartphone non esistevano
non si andava in giro a far foto così
semplicemente vendo c una macchina
fotografica in tasca o
wikipedia in tasca o appunto i social e
quindi forse anche come
consumavamo le immagini era diverso e
anche la nostra soglia di attenzione era
diversa
e quindi
ai 20 anni siamo un gruppo di amici
venti anni fa abbiamo creato quella che
oggi si chiama
street art
e che è diventato poi non la chiamerei
un movimento artistico però di sicuro un
qualcosa che si è mosso a livello
internazionale
sicuramente in tutte le capitali europeo
e ed oggi anche anche nelle piccole
città
non metropolitane
[Musica]
di fatto inserire un opera all'interno
dello spazio pubblico e
reinventare e
dare vita a quello spazio
voglio parlarvi di questo di questo
grosso intervento che ho realizzato nel
2008 ancona piazza oberdan questa è la
piazza ovviamente senza senza disegni
e quando quando devo lavorare in un
contesto cerco sempre di lavorare in
modo 6 specifica quindi faccio una serie
di ricerche
cerco di capire quelle che sono le
realtà sociali le realtà artistiche
gli stimoli
l'urbanistica della città la storia
della città quindi il contesto in cui mi
ritrovo trovo a lavorare
una volta individuato a ho avuto un po
di fatto della ricerca avuto degli
stimoli
cerco di capire che cosa posso
come posso abitare quello spazio
è un qualcosa che non fanno in molti
street artist soprattutto quelli che
arrivano dal dai graffiti perché più
un'occupazione un po violenta dello
spazio spesso e volentieri
in questo caso mi accusi colpi dalla
pinacoteca della città
una pala d'altare è fatta a lorenzo
lotto che la madonna incoronata dagli
angeli
la classica madonna con bambino
e nella parte alta si vedono questi
questi due angeli che posano sulla sulla
testa della madonna corona
stava dipingendo quest'opera che come
vedete insomma è grande più di 12 metri
quattro piani è l'ultimo giorno
ci hanno messo più o meno una settimana
l'ultimo giorno viene in mente di girare
la testa della madonna di coppa ma
perché faccio st madonna gigantesca in
questa piazza alla fine è lì già nella
pinacoteca diamogli un twist quindi
ribalto la testa della madonna ribalta
destra di gesù bambino così per gioco e
mentre stavo chiedendo la testa della
madonna proprio l'ultimo giorno 12 metri
altezza sento dell'ire urla
e mi giro e vedo una ragazza che fa così
dico averi e fan della street art a
bravi artisti voi che mettete i colori
della città
no era arrabbiatissimo diceva ma come vi
permettete non ti cosa fai vergognati io
sono rimasto un po non ho preso un po in
contropiede ha cercato di ma guarda non
è che faccio niente per un gesto
dispregiativo una mancanza di
male era già nata via e non sono nemmeno
potuto ragionare
sono i mastri un po
scioccato o comunque il desidero a
questo intervento finisco questo
risultato
scendo giù
guardo l'opera e dico beh porco cane
un po forte e vedo sento delle urla e
vedo una signora ma signora potrebbe mia
nonna tipo da lontano che fa così io
dico porco che è un'altra
no lei invece era contentissima diceva
bravissimo bravissimo
bellissimo
a quel punto io rimasto un po
stupito perché quella reazione me la
sarei aspettata una ragazza di 25 30
anni e l'indignazione da parte di mia
nonna che tre domeniche va in chiesa
sgrana rosai invece sarà felicissima e
allora io le ho chiesto signora ma cosa
ci vede grazie mille ma mi dica una cosa
cos'è cosa ci vede lei mi dice io vedo
la madonna che prega per noi con gli
occhi rivolti in cielo perché i cattivi
vogliono mettere le mani sulla città e
juris mi ha detto signora grazie non è
che le ho detto guardi l'abbiamo fatto
in tre manches aveva tempo per fa un
bozzetto comune ognuno ha fatto un po
quello che pensava fosse giusto e questo
il risultato però insomma
in realtà
come spesso poi accade ma data
un'interpretazione che ha quale non
avevo pensato
e
e di fatto da un lato mi sono reso conto
che l'opera d'arte quando effettivamente
funziona come opera d'arte
funziona come specchio e allora le
persone possono vedere loro stessi o
possono proiettare nell'opera d'arte
quelle che sono le loro paure o i loro
desideri
e di come l'opera d'arte nello spazio
pubblico funzioni veramente come un
gioco collettivo come un qualcosa di
collettivo e che quindi
molti dei significati non vengono
vengono necessariamente
dati dall'autore coscientemente ma
vengono anche regalati dagli osservatori
a volte inflitti o come nel caso della
ragazza
un altro un altro ricordo che
del quale volevo raccontarvi è questo
questa mostra appunto della
presentazione del museo del novecento
nel 2012 il museo del novecento è museo
d'arte moderna
a milano in piazza duomo accanto a
palazzo reale dove le grandi mostre
internazionali passano e
mi hanno invitato a fare appunto la
performance di due settimane due
settimane incredibili in cui ho lavorato
dalla mattina alla sera come assistente
una maratona di disegni e di disegni che
escono fuori da dai miei quadri proprio
per citare quella che è latitude della
street art
e
andata talmente bene che dopo queste
settimane abbiamo prorogato perché una
volta che poi la mostra tutta la vita
era un po un peccato this allestirla e e
non dà la possibilità ad altre persone
poi di vederla terminata
e nello specifico quando installato
quest'opera è stata la prima il primo
quadro in quasi due metri per un metro e
mezzo
il nome della grande mostra del museo si
chiamava il pregiudizio universale e mi
ricordo che quando appeso il primo
quadro
questo mi sono allontanato ho fatto tre
passi dietro ha avuto un brivido sulla
schiena ho sentito proprio come le opere
di picasso che sono al piano superiore
dei futuristi del dell'avanguardia dei
surrealisti
fossero lì accanto a me cioè
improvvisamente questo gioco che io
facevo con questi miei amici in quel
momento lo stavo facendo con i più
grandi artisti
della storia dell'arte al mondo del
novecento e lì ho avuto proprio un
brivido ho capito che il gioco si faceva
serio
il gioco si fa strada serio e mi ricorda
rita sono anche mi sono anche un po
spaventato perché in un certo senso è
stato un po è stato un punto di non
ritorno
a quel punto era un artista potevo più
girarci intorno è un artista i miei
colleghi erano picasso allora da vinci
michelangelo di champs è stato molto
bello ma anche abbastanza
abbastanza forte
quindi questo gioco mi ha portato anche
questi contesti istituzionali
come museo del novecento
queste sono altre
foto delle stazioni con 500 metri quadri
che io ho praticamente ribaltato la musa
non se l'aspettavano esso arrivato con
mio assistente alla mia squadra
già preparavamo una mostra museale
quindi le ho veramente presi contropiede
però alla fine il risultato è stato
incredibile anche per me
un altro un altro invito che avuto
un'altra un altro contesto istituzionale
è il primo
tribunale
a ricevere un'opera da parte di un urban
artist o comunque da chi ha fatto che
arriva dal dall'underground è stato
quest'opera ed il tribunale di rieti
vorrei faccio vedere un'altra
al macro questa è ancora lì quindi se
passate a roma
fate un salto al magro se io anzianità
quest'opera si chiama voi volete più di
molti passeri o in art we trust
e
illustra poi rottura del capitalismo
occidentale
dove appunto i soldi alla fine la fanno
da padrone
ovviamente lo slogan in qualche modo
voleva essere un po ottimista e
raccontare che invece no invece l'arte
diversa e quando poi proprio ad esempio
boys dice costo uguale capital quindi
poi anche l'arte poi alla fine diventa
diventa capitale diventa soldi e gestita
e il valore di un'opera si si si decide
in base a quanto quest'opera si vende
impastano e allora questo questo slogan
voleva essere invece proprio mezzo museo
nel museo della capitale invece un modo
per per dire che no che in realtà noi
crediamo nell'arte a prescindere in
questo gioco che è che l'altra e allora
questo gioco serio e questo gioco fatto
come un'opera che diventa un'opera
collettiva
e che forse proprio per la collettività
serve per mantenere anche vivo il
ricordo
quest'ultimo disegno che ho fatto per
willy l'anno scorso a paliano che è il
paese di willy e mi ricorderò sempre
quando la zia di willy questa donna
capoverdiana
nera ma preso le mani ho guardato negli
occhi e
piange scese le lacrime è anche a me e
mi ha detto
grazie grazie a tutti i parenti meno
tempo hanno ringraziato è stato un
momento bellissimo e le manchi tu io
guardando il disegno che hai fatto
mi sembra di vedere lui di veder quelli
che mi dice bella zii nun te preoccupà e
me l'ha detto in ciociaro e credo sia
stato uno dei momenti più più più belli
della mia carriera di
di artista che gioca con le immagini
quindi giocate seriamente e giocate
date sfogo alle vostre passioni
credeteci e con l'augurio che anche voi
domani sarete trasportati da queste
passioni da questo gioco
a creare o in situazioni
alle quali non avevate pensato
grazie